maligayang pagbabalik sa Quantum Computing sa Praktika ako ay si Olivia Lanes noong nakaraang pagkakataon ay dumaan tayo sa isang halimbawa ng isang
Quantum Computing na diskarte sa isang optimization problem na kilala bilang Max Cut gamit ang QUBO formulation
medyo malalim tayo nakapunta ngunit iyon ay isa lamang na halimbawa ng isang diskarte ngayon ay tatalakayin natin ang mga near-term na aplikasyon
nang mas malawak at paunlarin ang ating intuisyon para sa iba't ibang uri ng mga problema na inaasahan nating makahanap ng kapaki-pakinabang na Quantum na solusyon
para sa at makita ang ilang kamakailang mga halimbawa ng ilang mahalagang gawain na ginawa sa aming komunidad sa utility
scale dati ay maikli nating tinalakay na hindi lahat ng mga problema ay nangangailangan ng karagdagang computational power
tiyak na Quantum Computing para malutas nang mahusay ang mga ito ang mga problema na ito ang iyong pinakakilala
arithmetic pag-scroll sa social media marahil ay paglalaro ng Tetris Doom o iba pang mga video game malawak na itinuturing natin
ang mga ito na madaling mga problema sa kabilang banda mayroon mga napaka-mahirap na problema tulad ng paghahanap ng mga pangunahing salik ng napakalaking
mga integer at ito ang batayan ng RSA encryption at kung ano ang algorithm ni Shor ay talagang idinisenyo para malutas ang isa pa
halimbawa ay ang paghahanap ng solusyon sa isang unsorted data set ito ay maaaring sa teorya ay malutas ng quantum algorithm na kilala
bilang Grover's algorithm gayunpaman karamihan ng mga eksperto ay sumasang-ayon na ang mga uri ng algorithm na ito ay nangangailangan ng
implementasyon ng error correction at wala pa tayo roon sa teknolohikal na pagsasalita kaya habang nagpapatuloy tayo sa
aralin at sa iyong Quantum educational journey tandaan na naghahanap tayo ng Sweet Spot na ito dito sa kalagitnaan
ito ay isang mahirap na problema ngunit iyon din ang nagpapasaya nito isang bagay na hindi pa natin napag-usapan
nang maraming beses ay ang computational complexity theory isa sa mga dahilan ay ang maaaring maging medyo nakakatakot ito at oo
kumplikado ang computational complexity theory ay ang larangan ng computer science na layunin na uriin ang mga computational problem
ayon sa kung gaano sila kahirap mayroon isang tonelada ng iba't ibang mga complexity class sa classical Computing ngunit ang pinaka-
pundamental ay ang mga P problem ang mga ito ay mga problema na maaaring malutas sa polynomial time habang nagsasala ang sukat ng
problema ibig sabihin ay madali silang malutas ang susunod na mas mahirap na uri ng problema ay mga NP problem na
kumakatawan sa non-deterministic polynomial ang mga ito ay mga problema na ang mga sagot ay maaaring mapatunayan sa polynomial time ngunit hindi
kinakailangang malutas susunod ay ang NP complete at ngayon ay pumapasok na tayo sa mga talagang mapaghamong problema na walang
kilalang polynomial na solusyon dito naninirahan ang mga sikat na problema tulad ng traveling salesman problem at kahit ang laro
Sudoku ngayon nang lumabas ang Quantum Computing kahit man lang sa teorya maraming tao ang naggugol ng malaking pagsisikap na subukan
malaman kung anong klase ng mga problema ang mga bagong uri ng computer na ito ay makakalutas nang mahusay isang bagong klase ng
mga problema ay naimbento na tinatawag na bounded error quantum polynomial problems o bqp para maikli ang kanilang mahigpit na kahulugan ay
medyo mahaba ngunit ito ang klase ng decision problem na malulutas ng isang quantum computer sa polynomial time na may maliit na
pagkakataon ng error mayroon pagkakataon ng error dahil ang Quantum measurement ay likas na random ngunit ang error
probability ay maaaring maging arbitrarily maliit ngayon lahat ng mga klase na ito ay naninirahan sa isang mas malaking klase na tinatawag nating pspace at dito
sa tingin natin naninirahan ang bqp kaugnay ng lahat ng iba pang uri ng mga problema ngunit napakahirap na patunayan ito nang tiyak
sa matematika mapapansin mo na ang mga bqp Quantum problem ay hindi kinakailangang nagtutumpak sa mga NP complete na problema
gayunpaman maaaring nakakita ka pa rin ng ilang Quantum Computing na diskarte na layunin na malutas ang mga NP complete na problema bakit ito
isang karaniwang maling akala ay ang walang punto sa pag-explore ng mga solusyon
sa mga problema tulad ng traveling salesman at iba pang NP complete na problema para sa isang quantum computer o anumang problema o isang
matematikal na patunay para sa isang Quantum speedup ay hindi nahanap gayunpaman hindi ito kinakailangang magiging ganoon
ang paghanap ng matematikal na patunay na ang isang Quantum algorithm ay mas mabilis kaysa sa classical na katumbas nito ay bihira ang Shor at
Grover ay dalawa sa iilang mga halimbawa kung saan ito ay nagawa na hanggang ngayon ngunit iyon ay okay sa katunayan ang mga computer
scientist ay hindi pa rin nakakapagtunayan na ang mga klase ng p at NP ay magkaiba kahit na ang lahat ng intuisyon
ay nagsasabi sa atin na dapat sila rin ang paghahambing ng dalawang algorithm at kung paano sila nagsasala ay madalas na tumitingin sa pinakamasamang kaso
scenario para sa bawat isa ito ay lubos na posible na sa praktika ang pinakamasamang kaso scenario ay hindi ang makikita natin sa totoong buhay kaya
huwag tayong mabigo sa halip ay ipinakilala natin ang ideya ng mga heuristic na solusyon kung isa ka
eksperimentalista alam mo na at minamahal na ang mga uri ng solusyon na ito ang isang heuristic ay anumang diskarte sa paglutas ng isang
problema na pragmatic ngunit hindi kinakailangang optimal at iyon ay mahusay dahil ang mga solusyon ay hindi kinakailangang
maging optimal para maging napaka-kapaki-pakinabang halimbawa isipin ang isang financial na aplikasyon hindi pa tayo nakahanap ng isang
exponential na speedup para sa karamihan ng mga Financial algorithm na maaaring gamitin ng Quantum ngunit hindi iyon kinakailangang mahalaga hindi natin kailangan ng isang optimal na solusyon
sa pananalapi man lang dahil ang isang solusyon na kahit 1% lamang ay mas mahusay ay maaaring katumbas ng bilyun-bilyon ng dolyar
kita kaya paano natin malalaman kung aling mga use case at problema ang maaaring angkop para sa Quantum Computing ngayon at sa iyon
ibig sabihin ko ay mayroon makabuluhang dahilan para maniwala na ang Quantum utility o kahit ang Advantage ay matatagpuan alinman ngayon o
sa medyo malapit na hinaharap marahil ay mas madali na unang pangalanan ang mga bagay na tiyak na hindi dapat mayroon ang problema
hindi ito maaaring mangailangan ng napakalaking bilang ng mga qubit wala pa tayong mga processor na may libu-libo hanggang milyun-milyon na qubit na available iyon ang isa sa mga pangunahing dahilan
kung bakit ang algorithm ni Shor at katulad ay napaka-malayo pa rin ang mga circuit ay hindi rin maaaring maging hindi kapani-paniwalang malalim mahirap para sa akin
sabihin sa iyo nang eksakto kung anong circuit depth ang hindi gagana dahil depende ito sa napakaraming mga salik ngunit sa pangkalahatan kung ang iyong
eksperimento ay nangangailangan ng isang depth na hindi mo pa nakita sa literatura ay maaaring mayroon kang mahirap na oras at
sa wakas anumang uri ng algorithm na alam nating mangangailangan ng error correction ay hindi pa maaaring gawin kung ano ang dapat nating hanapin gayunpaman ay mga eksperimento na gumagamit ng
karamihan ng mga qubit na available sa anumang ibinigay na qpu nagdiin din tayo sa
kahalagahan ng error mitigation at suppression at sa wakas ay dapat mayroong malinaw na extension sa mga hinaharap na
aplikasyon na magiging mahalaga para sa lipunan at na maaari naming makita sa huli na humahantong sa Quantum
Advantage ngayon pag-usapan natin ang ilang mga halimbawa ng mga use case na nahuhulog sa tatlong pangunahing kategorya na aming
natukoy bilang pinaka-malamang na makakita ng mga pabor na resulta sa malapit hanggang katamtamang
term ang unang lugar ay ang simulation ng kalikasan napag-usapan na natin ito dati mayroon
napakaraming mga pagkakataon para sa mga quantum computer na mapabuti ang pananaliksik na ginagawa sa molekular at atomic na antas
at ang dahilan para dito ay ang kasalukuyang mga classical na pamamaraan ay limitado ng pundamental na hindi episyenteng matematikal
na mga paglalarawan ng mga istruktura ng atom ang pag-iimbak at pag-manipula ng isang Quantum State ay nangangailangan ng exponential na halaga ng mga resources
sa isang classical computer ngunit maaaring magawa nang mahusay sa isang quantum computer at iyon ang nagpapaganda ng material simulation
at chemical modeling bilang ilan sa mga pinaka-promising na lugar ng aplikasyon mas tiyak ay maaari itong humantong sa
mga pag-unlad sa carbon dioxide sequestration mga alternatibong baterya o ang paglikha ng mga bagong gamot ang ilan sa
mga algorithm na espesyal na may kaugnayan sa lugar na ito ay ang variational quantum eigensolver o vqe na ginagamit para
tantiyahin ang ilang mga katangian ng isang material tulad ng equilibrium o minimum energy states ang isa pang halimbawa ay ang
time dynamic simulation o TDS ang algorithm na iyon ay ginagamit para tantiyahin ang mga response function o spectral properties ng
mga material at gusto ko ring banggitin ang isang baguhan ang sample based quantum diagonalization na sa tingin namin ay maririnig natin nang mas marami
tungkol dito sa malapit na hinaharap ang susunod na lugar ng aplikasyon ay ang optimization ngayon ang optimization ay medyo
ubiquitous sa Computing tulad ng maaari mong isipin kaya ang mga use case ay medyo marami at iba-iba
gayunpaman ang ilang mga halimbawa na marinig natin nang maraming beses ay ang portfolio optimization sa pananalapi industrial na disenyo at pati na rin
distribusyon at supply chain ang pinakakaraniwang algorithm na malamang na maririnig mo na may kaugnayan sa optimization ay ang isa na
natalakay na natin nang may kalaliman ang quantum approximate optimization algorithm o
qaoa sa wakas ang isang lugar na nagkaroon ng maraming kagalakan sa nakaraang ilang taon ay ang quantum machine learning ngayon
sa tingin ko ay makatarungan na sabihin na mukhang ang qml ay hindi mangyayaring kasing bilis ng simulation sa lahat ng posibilidad ngunit gayon pa man mayroon
ilang kahanga-hangang mga algorithm na patuloy na ginagawa ng mga tao na tumutugma sa ilang napaka-mahalagang use
case ang ilan sa mga posibleng use case na ito ay natural language processing network traffic analysis at kahit fraud
detection sa mga financial transaction ang mga may kaugnayan na algorithm sa lugar na ito ay ang quantum support vector
machine quantum neural networks at quantum generative adversarial networks ngayon upang linawin ang tatlong
grupo na aming tinalakay ay malawak na mga lugar ng aplikasyon kapwa kapaki-pakinabang na tandain na sa komunidad mayroon din
benepisyo sa mga grupo na nagtatrabaho nang magkasama na nakatuon sa isang tiyak na paksa ang IBM ay nanguna ng isang inisyatibo kamakailan
na tinatawag na mga Working Group para subukang tulungan ang mga collaborator na makilala at lumikha ng produktibong Synergy sa apat na tiyak
na lugar ng Healthcare at life science materials at HPC high energy physics at
optimization narito ang aming mga kasalukuyang grupo at ang mga entity na kasangkot sa mga pagsisikap na iyon kung gusto mong marinig nang higit pa tungkol sa
kung ano ang ginagawa ng mga working group ay nakalakip namin ang apat sa kanilang mga white paper sa description sa ibaba ngayon tulad ng sinabi ko
sa tingin ko ang pinakamabuting gawin sa puntong ito sa kurso ay gumugol ng ilang oras sa pag-explore kung anong uri ng mga problema ang ginagawa ng mga tao sa
Cutting Edge ng teknolohiyang ito at pagpapaunlad ng ating intuisyon para malaman kung anong uri ng mga algorithm ang gagana at kung paano
ilapat ang mga ito at bago tayo magsimula ay gusto ko lang gawing napakalinaw na ang pangunahing layunin dito ay hindi maunawaan ang bawat
detalye ng mga eksperimento ang ganitong uri ng pagsusuri ay maaaring napaka-nakakatakot kahit para sa mga eksperto kung ang papel ay kaunti
labas ng iyong lugar ng kaalaman ang layunin ay simpleng tulungan ang pagpapaunlad ng intuisyon para sa mga uri ng mga problema na
quantum computers ay mabuti at kung paano harapin ang mga ito at kung interesado ka sa mas mataas na mga detalye at nag-spark ito ng ilang
mga ideya ng iyong sarili talagang hinihikayat kita na pumunta at basahin ang mga buong papel mismo ang mga tiyak na use case at
mga papel na bibigyan natin ng malalim na pagtingin ay ang mga ito una ay tuklasin natin ang isang papel na nagtatalakayin ng
simulation ng hadron Dynamics na nahuhulog sa high energy physics na kategorya susunod ay titingnan tayo ng isang optimization
problema tiyak na biased field counter adiabatic Quantum optimization at sa wakas ay titingnan tayo ng isa pa
simulation na problema ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ay nakatuon sa mRNA isang mahalagang molekula para sa
paggawa ng gamot at therapeutic kung pamilyar ka o hindi sa mga papel na ito iyon ay walang problema ay
dadaan tayo sa lahat ng tatlo ay mga mahalagang papel na tumutuon sa mga problema ng malaking sukat at nagpapakita kung paano ang mga quantum
computer ay nagsisimulang gamitin bilang isa pang paraan ng siyentipikong pagtatanong una ay ang pagsimulate ng hadron
Dynamics at mag-delve tayo sa isang papel ng grupo ni Martin Savage sa University of Washington na tinatawag na Quantum
simulations of hadron Dynamics in the Schwinger model using 112
qubits kung hindi ka isang high energy physicist maaari ka pa ring maging pamilyar sa termino na hadron tulad ng sa
Large Hadron Collider o ang LHC na siyang napakalaking particle accelerator na 27 kilometro sa circumference na ginawa
posible ang sa wakas ay obserbahan ang Higgs boson ngayon ang hadron ay isang subatomic composite particle na gawa sa iba pang maliliit
na mga particle na tinatawag na quarks ang ilang mga halimbawa ay magiging mga neutron at proton para sa kaunting konteksto ang LHC ay itinayo
para hayaan ang pag-aaral ng pundamental na physics at kung ano ang nangyayari sa mga particle kapag nagbanggaan sila sa napakataas na mga enerhiya
sa circular tube na ito sa pamamagitan ng paggawa nito ang mga siyentipiko ay umaasang matuto nang higit pa tungkol sa kung paano lumitaw ang maagang Uniberso
at tulad ng nabanggit ko nang dati ay ginagamit din ito para mahanap ang boson na siyang isang mahirap makuha na particle na responsable para sa masa ng
mga pundamental na particle ngayon sa prinsipyo ang mga interaksyon ng mga particle na ito ay maaaring
ma-simulate mula simula hanggang katapusan gamit ang isang sapat na makapangyarihang quantum computer hindi pa tayo nandoon ngunit ang progreso
ay nagagawa ngayon ang Schwinger model ay isang simpleng modelo na ginagamit para i-simulate ang ilan sa mga Dynamics na ito at lumabas bilang isa sa
mga pinakasikat na modelo ng pagpipilian ang mga detalye ng modelo ay hindi napakamahalaga para sa ngayon ngunit para sa mga
curious ito ay isang modelo na naglalarawan ng gawi ng mga elektron at positron na nagkikipag-interaksyon sa pamamagitan ng mga photon sa 1 + 1 D
Dimensions ibig sabihin ay mayroong isang spatial Dimension at oras ang modelo ay may maraming pagkakatulad sa Quantum
chromodynamics na naglalarawan kung paano nagkikipag-interaksyon ang mga quark at hadron ngayon iyon ay napaka-mahirap na i-simulate kaya ang
Schwinger model ay madalas na ginagamit bilang isang toy model para i-invest ang ilang phenomena na talagang karaniwan sa
parehong ngayon ang paraan ng ating pagpapatuloy ng halimbawang ito at ng natitira sa mga halimbawa na pinili ko dito ay
sa pamamagitan ng pagtatanong sa ating sarili ng isang serye ng mga tanong ang una ay bakit mayroon tayong dahilan para maniwala na ang pag-simulate nito
sa isang quantum computer ay gagana sa lahat sa kasong ito ang mga elektron at positron sa Schwinger model ay may screening
effect na nagiging sanhi ng mga correlation sa pagitan ng malalayong mga fermion na mag-decay nang exponentially sa paghihiwalay at ibig sabihin nito ay mayroon
hindi gaanong maraming long range na interaksyon mula sa isang qubit sa isang panig ng chip patungo sa isa pa sa kabilang panig ng chip
na alam nating napaka-madaling magkaroon ng error kaya ito ay talagang maganda para sa hardware na available natin ngayon susunod ay
interesante ba ang paksa na ito kaya umaasa ako na medyo nakumbinsi ko na kayo na oo ang high energy physics ay may malaking
interes handa ang mga tao na gumastos ng bilyun-bilyon ng dolyar para itayo ang LHC at libu-libo at mga siyentipiko at
mga technician sa buong mundo ay nagtakda ng kanilang buhay sa larangang ito iyon ang kahalagahan nito ngunit ang
Schwinger model ay simplistic at hindi idinisenyo para sumasaklaw ng tatlong spatial na Dimension gayunpaman ito ay isang
mahalagang modelo dahil nagbibigay pa rin ito ng kasalukuyang natatestang mga hiwa at kapaki-pakinabang na simplipikasyon ng isang buong
Teorya sa wakas kung paano ginawa ang trabahong ito o kung anong diskarte ang gagamitin nila kung naghahanap sila na ipagpatuloy ang gawain sa
simulation type na mga eksperimento ang vqe ay isa sa mga pinakakaraniwang diskarte at ang unang hakbang ay halos palaging pareho
ihanda ang ground state sa kasong ito ito ay isang vacuum state at sa eksperimentong ito ay gumamit sila ng isang bagong bersyon ng vqe na tinatawag na SC
adapt vqe para ihanda ang parehong ground state at ang hadron wave packet sa ibabaw ng vacuum ang susunod na hakbang ay ang
hayaang mag-evolve o kumalag ang mga hadron sa panahon sa wakas kailangan nating tukuyin ang mga
observable na gusto nating detektahin ngayon kung ang mga hakbang na iyon ay mukhang pamilyar sa iyo minus ang Hadron wave
packet na bahagi iyon ay dahil ang mga hakbang na ito ay halos katulad ng aming natalakay sa qaoa na halimbawa sa nakaraang episode
sana ay nagsisimula ka nang makakita ng ilang mga pattern na lumabas dito ang mga bahagi na kailangan para sa vqe ay halos katulad sa qaoa
nagsisimula tayo sa isang pamilyar na estado dito ang vacuum state at pagkatapos ay hinayaan nating mag-evolve ito sa panahon na may isang serye ng exponentiated
hamiltonians na nahahati sa mga pinamamahalaan na mga piraso kung saan ang n ay ang bilang ng mga Division ang tanging malaking pagkakaiba dito
ay lumilikha tayo ng wave packet ng hadron na nakasentro sa loob ng aming circuit bago natin simulan ang pag-evolve nito kaya paano ito
nagagawa nang ang vacuum state ay ang ground state at medyo natakpan na natin kung paano i-map ito ngayon ang paghahanda ng Hadron
wave packet ay medyo naiiba sa vacuum na ito ang isang hadron ay maaaring maging exciting sa pamamagitan ng paglikha ng isang fermion anti-fermion pair sa
mga katabing site sa pamamagitan ng paghahanda ng isang superposition ng mga ganitong hadron sa iba't ibang mga lokasyon ang isang arbitrary wave
packet ay maaaring ihanda ang mga may-akda ay nagsentro ng kanilang wave packet sa kalagitnaan ng circuit para obserbahan ang ebolusyon
nang hindi lalampas sa isang hangganan ngunit tandaan na ang pangalan ng laro kapag nagtatrabaho sa maingay na qpu ay panatilihing
mapamahalaan ang circuit depth para gawin ito ang SC adapt vqe protocol ay gumagamit ng symmetry at
mga hierarchy sa mga length scale para matukoy ang mga low depth Quantum circuits para sa State preparation ang ideya ay ang ito
ay lilikha ng isang ansatz na may mas maliit na bilang ng mga parameter na katumbas ng mas mababaw na depth ang mas maraming detalye ay matatagpuan siyempre
sa papel kaysa sa aming oras para saklawin dito kaya siguraduhing tingnan ito ngayon tingnan natin ang mga resulta ang eksperimento na ito ay pinatakbo sa
isang IBM Quantum Heron device at nagpatupad ng ilang iba't ibang uri ng error mitigation at suppression
kasama ang isang mas kamakailang teknik na tinatawag na operator decoherence renormalization pati na rin ang dynamical decoupling zero noise
extrapolation at Pauli twirling ngayon subukan nating bigyang-kahulugan ang data ang observable na talagang
susukat natin para obserbahan kung paano kumakalat ang wave packet ay tinatawag na chiral condensate na medyo
abstract ngunit ito ay karaniwang isang superfluid phase ng mga hadron ngayon makikita natin ang wave packet na nakasentro dito sa mga
site na itinakda para patakbuhin ang eksperimentong ito kung saan ang kulay ay katumbas ng chiral condensate ang
kaliwang panig ay nagpapakita ng mga error-free na resulta mula sa simulator habang ang kanang panig ay nagpapakita ng mga resulta mula sa IBM quantum
computer Torino ideally ang mga ito ay magiging mga salamin ng isa't isa dahil sa symmetry kaya makikita mo na mayroon
ilang mga imperpeksyon ngayon ang vertical y axis na ito ay katumbas ng mga piraso ng oras na
sinukat ko nang dati kaya bakit hindi tayo kumuha ng ilang pahalang na mga hiwa sa una at huling mga time step ng data para makita
kung ano ang nangyayari sa wave packet sa Oras t katumbas ng 1 dito sa Orange na katumbas ng
hiwa na ito maaari mong makita na ang chiral condensate ay makitid at localized ito ay tumutugma rin nang talagang mabuti sa
simulation na ginawa para sa paghahambing sa t katumbas ng 14 gayunpaman ito ay mas malawak at mas hindi
localized marahil ang paghahambing sa simulator ay hindi masyadong perpekto ngayon ngunit maaari ka pa ring malinaw na makakita ng napakamagandang kasunduan sa pagitan ng Teorya at ng data
na nakakatulong sa konklusyon ito ay isang napakamagandang halimbawa ng uri ng simulation work na maaaring hindi mo muna naiisip
na ilapat ang mga quantum computer gayunpaman sa katunayan maaari mo at ito ay gumagana hindi ito perpekto ngunit hindi mo kailangang maging isang
particle physics expert para makita na ang quantum computer ay tumpak na hinuhulaan ang panlabas na pagpapalawak ng wave packet
na eksaktong inaasahan nating mahanap sana ang mga hinaharap na gawain sa lugar na ito ay magpapatuloy at ang mga high energy physicist
ay magpapatuloy na makahanap ng mga paraan para isama ang Quantum Computing sa kanilang mga work stream ang layunin ay malutas ang mga theoretical na problema nang mas tumpak at
ang mga hindi maaaring gawin nang classical at gamitin ang mga eksperimento para tanggapin o tanggihan ang mga teorya sa pag-asa na matuklasan ang bagong
physics na bumuo ng mga pinahusay na detector at humahantong sa mas mabuting pag-unawa ng kalikasan sa pinaka-pundamental nito
antas ang aming susunod na halimbawa ay nakatuon sa optimization at magiging isang malalim na pagsisid sa isang papel na tinatawag na biased field
digitized counter adiabatic Quantum optimization na ginawa ng mga miyembro ng kipu quantum team sa
University of the Basque Country sa Spain magsisimula tayo tulad ng ginawa natin dati
na may isang serye ng mga kahulugan ang una ay counter adiabatic na isang uri ng ebolusyon na pinipigilan ang mga non-adiabatic
na mga epekto na nararanasan ng isang sistema anuman ang bilis ng mga prosesong iyon alalahanin ang adiabatic theorem mula sa
nakaraang episode karaniwan ay kailangan mong hayaang mag-evolve ang isang sistema nang napakabagal kung nais mong manatili ito sa ground state
ito ay isang malaking problema dahil mas mabagal ang kailangan nating hayaang mag-evolve ang mga bagay mas maraming oras ang mayroon tayo para sa mga error na
mangyari ang counter adiabatic driving na madalas na pinaikli bilang CD ay layunin na labanan ito sa pamamagitan ng
pagdaragdag ng mga termino na nagkokonter sa mga hindi gustong excitation ang pangunahing ideya dito ay pabilisin ang buong eksperimento at
bawasan ang Quantum circuit depth sa pamamagitan ng pagpigil ng mga excitation na maaaring humantong sa mga spurious
Transitions ngayon pag-usapan natin kung ano ang isang bias field ang iba pang mga iterative na algorithm tulad ng vqe ay kumukuha ng mga classical na parameter sa
mga estadong ito at gumagamit ng mga classical na optimizer para maghanap ng maraming dimensional na parameter space para sa set na iyon
na nagbubunga ng minimum na expectation value para sa isang fixed hamiltonian sa kasong ito ay binabago nila ang hamiltonian sa bawat
pagkakataon na gumagalaw nang adiabatically mula sa isang kilalang kaso papunta sa kaso ng interes ngunit dahil walang mga classical na parameter na
pinipili at walang variational wave function paano mo ia-update ang iyong estado mula sa isang pass sa hamiltonian patungo sa susunod na kaya
nagdadagdag sila ng isang bias field sa hamiltonian anuman ang pinakamababang energy state mula sa nakaraang run ay nagdaragdag sila ng termino sa
hamiltonian para i-bias ang estado pabor doon kaya bakit ang eksperimentong ito ay may
Interes nang una ay ito ay isang bagong diskarte na maaaring ilapat nang mas pangkalahatan sa iba pang mga optimization na problema
ngunit sa kasong ito ay inilapat nila ito sa isang ising spin glass problem tulad ng tinalakay natin nang dati ang maraming combinatorial
optimization na problema ay maaaring muling i-formulate bilang paglutas para sa mga low energy states ng ising hamiltonians ang ising
model ay isang serye ng mga microscopic spin na ipinamamahagi sa isang array ang modelo ay maaaring gamitin para ilarawan ang isang spin glass kung saan
ang magnetization ay disordered karaniwang ang maliliit na magnetic moment ay nakaorientasyon nang random sa array at
bakit sa tingin natin ito gagana nang medyo natakpan na natin kung paano tayo lumalaban sa dalawang tipikal na isyu na matatagpuan sa
mga variational algorithm nang tinakpan natin ang mga kahulugan ng papel ngunit para ibuod ang algorithm na kanilang
iminumungkahi ay nagpapabilis ng ebolusyon para bawasan ang circuit depth habang binibigyan din ng pagpigil ang mga non-adiabatic transitions
bukod pa rito ay hindi ito umaasa sa anumang classical optimization routine na maaaring maging isang isyu na humahantong sa Barren
plateaus at pagiging natigil sa local Minima sa wakas tinitiyak din ng mga may-akda na i-align ang mga interaksyon sa problema
hamiltonian na may hardware connectivity sa tunay na qpu na palaging napakahalaga sa wakas kung paano gumagana ito kaya
tulad ng sinabi ko walang mga classical optimizer na ginagamit dito tulad ng madalas nangyayari sa mga iterative Quantum algorithm
sa halip sa pamamagitan ng pagpapasok ng solusyon mula sa bawat iteration sa input para sa susunod na isa ang biased field digitized
Quantum optimization algorithm ay unti-unting pinipino ang ground state na dinadala ito nang mas malapit at mas malapit sa
huling evolved State at pinagsama sa counter adiabatic protocols maaari nating gawin ito kahit may maikli ang depth Quantum
circuits na dapat tumakbo nang maayos sa maingay na Hardware kaya nang isagawa ang eksperimento pinili ng mga may-akda na patakbuhin ang
algorithm sa 127 qubit IBM quantum computer Brisbane dito ay ipinapakita ng may-akda ang
etherization ng optimization algorithm para sa isang nearest neighbor randomly generated spin glass instance
na mahigit 100 qubits inihambing nila ang mga ideal simulation result mula sa dcq at bf dcq
pati na rin ang experimental result at nagpapakita rin sila ng resulta mula sa isang classical solver na tinatawag na gurobi bilang sanggunian ngayon
sa 10 iteration lamang ang BF dcq ay nagbibigay ng malaking pagpapabuti kumpara sa
dcq bagaman ang experimental result ay medyo naiiba sa ideal na resulta dahil sa ingay ang performance ay mas maganda pa rin
kaysa sa ideal dcq nagpapakita ito na marami pa ring napakagandang pag-unlad na nagagawa
tungkol sa Quantum optimization at magagandang resulta ay iniuulat sa mahigit 100 qubits sa isa sa mga unang
pagkakataon ang huli ngunit hindi ang pinakahumahalaga ay isang napaka-kawili-wiling papel na nag-eeksplora ng mRNA structure prediction mula sa aming mga kaibigan sa
Moderna Pharmaceuticals at ito ay tinatawag na mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers para magsimula kung tulad ko ay ilang taon na ang lumipas mula nang kumuha ng biology course maaari kang mag-refresh sa kung ano ang
mRNA ang messenger RNA ay isang uri ng RNA na kasangkot sa protein synthesis ito
ay karaniwang nagbabasa ng mga instruksyon na ibinibigay ng DNA ang secondary structure ng mRNA ay halos paano nakatiklop ang chain at
ang RNA secondary structure prediction problem ay ang problema ng paghahanap ng pinaka-matatag na folding ng pagkakasunod-sunod
ng mga base ng nucleotide na bumubuo ng DNA at RNA na magiging c g u at a ang
larawan na ito ay nagpapakita ng ilan sa mga karaniwang folding structure na matatagpuan sa mRNA ang bawat kulay na itinatampok dito ay nagpapakita ng isang
iba't ibang secondary structure ngunit ang eksaktong mga katangian para sa kung ano ang nagpapaganda ng isa sa mga istrukturang ito kaysa sa isa
ay hindi mabuting naiintindihan ang tanging magagawa natin ay alamin kung alin sa mga ito ang may pinakamababang libreng enerhiya kumpara sa
unfolded state at doon pumapasok ang mga quantum computer kaya bakit ang mga mRNA secondary structure
ay mahalaga nang tumpak na prediksiyon ng mga ito ay talagang mahalaga at hindi lamang pag-unawa sa DNA at sa ating mga gene kundi pati na rin
para sa Pagdidisenyo ng mga RNA based na Therapeutics tulad ng covid-19 vaccine mayroon dahilan para maniwala na ang diskarte sa
papel na ito ay gagana dahil ito ay matagal nang kilala na isang imposanteng optimization na problema para sa classical
computer dahil sa napakalaking bilang ng mga posibleng configuration at para sa ilang mga configuration ito ay talagang kilala na maging
isang NP complete na problema gayunpaman sa isang quantum computer maaari nating i-formulate ang secondary structure prediction bilang isang
binary optimization problem na alam nating kung paano harapin bukod pa rito ay mayroon na ebidensya sa literatura
ng tumpak na RNA prediction sa maliit na sukat Quantum devices at Quantum simulators kaya ang malinaw na tanong ay
gagana ba ito sa mas malalaking Hardware ang eksperimento ay ginagawa sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng tinatawag na conditional value
at risk variational Quantum eigensolver na siyang isang modipikasyon sa tradisyonal na vqe algorithm at
inaasahang makamit ang mas magandang convergence ang plot na ito ay nagpapakita ng distribusyon ng measurement
probabilities ng sample bit strings na may kaugnay na mga enerhiya para sa 42
nucleotide 80 qubit instance dito ang mga bit string ay sumisimbolo sa mga pairings ng
mga nucleotide ipinapakita nito na ang pinakamababang energy bit string ay may energy value na -140 na tumutugma sa pinakamababang
energy bit string na nahanap ng comparative classical solver kaya iyon ay maganda at ito ang optimal na folded
structure ng nucleotide chain batay sa pinakamababang energy bit string na nahanap ng hardware at
sa iyon ay nakarating na tayo sa konklusyon ng episode na ito ngayon ang layunin ko dito ay hindi ka labasan ng impormasyon gamit ang
mga detalye mula sa iba't ibang research paper tulad ng sinabi ko ay gusto ko lang bigyan ka ng sapat na konteksto para maunawaan ang
Cutting Edge na gawain sa larangan ngayon ang pag-asa ay na ito ay magpapagalaw ng ilang mga gear sa
isipan ng lahat at sa pamamagitan ng pagkita kung paano ang iba ay lumalapat sa mga problema ay magagawa mong gumawa ng mga koneksyon at magkaroon ng
kumpiyansa na subukan ang mga bagong Quantum eksperimento na maaaring hindi mo gagawin dati at hey marahil ang ilan sa mga ito ay hindi
magiging matagumpay at iyon ay okay iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ito ay pananaliksik sa pagsulong ay tandaan na ang mga uri ng mga problema na
interesado tayo ay maaaring ma-grupo alinman sa pamamagitan ng metodolohiya o ayon sa paksa at inilatag na natin ang mga naniniwala tayong
pinaka-promising sa maikling panahon tandaan na ang Quantum Computing ay hindi maganda para sa lahat at talagang ito ay isang
patunay lamang sa kung gaano kagaling tayo sa classical Computing dahil lang na sa tingin mo ay maaari mong ilapat ang Quantum Computing
sa isang problema ay hindi nangangahulugang magbubunga ito ng kawili-wiling mga resulta sa kasamaang palad kailangan mong isaalang-alang ang scaling circuit
depth ay isang double-edged sword kailangan itong maging malaki nang malaki para gumawa ng kawili-wiling gawain na hindi kaya ng classical
computer ngunit ngayon dahil sa hardware noise hindi natin maitulak ito sa napakalaking sukat dahil ang Fidelity ay
mababawasan ang lahat ay tungkol sa paghahanap ng sweet spot na iyon at pag-alam na ito ay isang gumagalaw na Target kaya maglaan ng oras sa pagitan
ngayon at ng susunod na episode para talagang mag-isip tungkol sa ilang mga problema na naranasan mo at kung paano mo gustong lapitan ang mga ito gamit ang kung ano ang
natutunan natin hanggang sa puntong ito maging creative at huwag limitahan ang sarili at kung mayroon kang anumang ideya kahit sa tingin mo ay sila ay kaunti
medyo baliw ipaalam sa akin sa mga comment sa ibaba salamat sa panonood at makikita kita sa susunod na pagkakataon